hello and welcome to today's global
covert 19 press conference and on other
health emergencies it is tuesday 9 18
january 2022
and my name is christian lindmeyer
as guests today as participants we have
a full room again and we'll start with
doctor tedros adam gabriel
who director general
dr mike ryan executive director for w
joe's health emergencies program
dr maria von kurkov technical lead on
covet 19.
dr sumiyas maminatan chief scientist
dr marian hila simao assistant director
general for access to medicines and
health products
dr
uh saucy fall assistant director general
for w joe's health emergency program and
responsible for emergency response
and
we have dr bruce elwood
um senior advisor to the director
general and the lead on act accelerator
and we have online with us
dr kate o'brien director for
immunization vaccines and biologicals
simultaneous translation is provided in
six official
languages and i believe
we have
portuguese as well
um
with this
let me hand over to director general for
his opening rocks and one more time
thank you for standing by for a bit late
start today
dr tedros
thank you thank you christian
good morning good afternoon and good
evening
the volcanic eruption near tonga and
subsequent tsunami
requires an urgent response
with telecommunications down
wh joe is on the ground in tonga helping
coordinate the response by channeling
information between u.n agencies
humanitarian partners
and the tongan government
information on the degree of destruction
is still being gathered but tableau will
do all it can
to support the people and government of
tonga
i visited tonga myself in 2019
i recognize how vulnerable to natural
disaster and the climate crisis the
country is
but also how resilient and resourceful
the people are
all the very best from doubleho and we
will do everything to support tonga
omikron continues to sweep the world
last week there were more than 18
million reported cases
the number of deaths remains stable for
the moment but we're concerned about the
impact omicron is having on already
exhausted health workers
and overburdened health systems
in some countries cases seem to have
peaked
which gives hope that the worst of this
latest wave is done with but
no countries out of the woods yet
i remain particularly concerned
about many countries that have low
vaccination rates as people are many
times more at risk of severe illness
and death
if they're unvaccinated
omicron may be less severe
on average of course
but
the narrative
that it is mild disease is misleading
hurts the overall response
and costs
more
lives
make no mistake
omicron is causing hospitalizations and
does
and even the less severe cases are
inundating health facilities
the virus is circulating far too
intensely with many still vulnerable
for many countries
the next few weeks remain really
critical for health workers and health
systems
i urge everyone to do their best to
reduce risk of infection
so that you can help take pressure off
the system
now is not the time to give up
and wave the white flag
we can still significantly reduce the
impact of the current wave by sharing
and using health tools effectively and
implementing public health and social
measures
that we know work
i'm proud kovacs delivered its 1 billion
dollars over the weekend
of course it's not enough and we should
do more
at the time of omicron
it remains more important than ever to
get vaccines to the unvaccinated
vaccines may be less effective at
preventing infection and transmission of
omicron than they were for
previous variants
but they still are exceptionally good at
preventing
serious disease and death
this is key to protecting hospitals from
becoming
overwhelmed we have been able to track
new variants like omicron and this virus
evolution in real time thanks to efforts
of thousands of scientists and experts
around the world
more than seven million
all genome sequences from 180 countries
have now been submitted to this aid
which was initially set up to track flu
this pandemic is nowhere near over and
with the incredible growth of omicron
globally
new variants are likely to emerge
which is why tracking and assessment
critical
new informations
new formulations
of vaccines are being developed and
assessed
for how they perform against omicron
and other strains
i'm concerned that unless that we change
the current model
we will enter a second and even more
destructive phase of vaccine inequity
we need to make sure we share current
vaccines equitably
and we develop
distributed manufacturing around the
world
we can only beat this virus
if we work together
and share health tools equitably
it's really that simple
on friday who recommended two new covet
19 treatments based on data from seven
trials
again increasing the arsenal of tools
used to fight severe illness and death a
rheumatoid arthritis drug
called
barista need
and a molecule antibody called
sotro vimab
again
the challenge is that high prices and
limited supply means access is limited
why is working with our partners in act
accelerator to negotiate lower prices
with manufacturers
and ensure supply will be available for
low and middle-income countries
we urge manufacturers to use who's covet
19 technology access pool
to share technology
know-how and voluntary licensing in
order to facilitate
increased production capacity globally
which would save the most lives
who's covered 19 clinical management
guidelines have been critical to policy
makers and health workers
so that they can access the latest
information on how best to treat
patients with copied 19.
sharing clinical data remains critical
so that who can generate up-to-date
scientific evidence regarding omicron
who invites all member states
health facilities and research networks
to voluntarily contribute to the who
global clinical platform for covet 19
which is available through our website
next week
the who executive board which is made up
of 34 member states will meet to discuss
the world's health challenges
the pandemic will remain at the
forefront
particularly how to more effectively
share tests
treatments and vaccines equitably
and to meet the 70 percent vaccine
target by july 2022
however
the impact of the pandemic on other
health issues has also been devastating
and member states will be discussing
how we can stop the backsliding and
recover together
who will be working to accelerate
progress on negotiations around the
pandemic accord
as well as sustainable financing
if we're serious about strengthening
health systems
preparing for future pandemics and
tackling the litany
of health challenges we collectively
face in a heating world
who and the whole global health
infrastructure
will need to be sustainably
financed reports from the global
pandemic monitoring board
the independent panel for pandemic
preparedness and response and the review
committee on the functioning of the
international health regulations all
recognized
the need for predictable and sustainable
financing
at all levels of the organization
we don't need more reports or speech
now is the moment for financing that
fits the health challenges of our time
this month
is cervical cancer awareness month
and i'm pleased to see both action and
advocacy taking place
yesterday serbia announced that this
year they would introduce vaccination
against human papilloma virus
or hpv
the pathogen responsible for 99
of cervical cancers
serbia will join 116 countries worldwide
that are vaccinating against this cancer
causing virus
and my sister princess dina meyer
who is a member of wh extra experts
group for the elimination of cervical
cancer
marked the anniversary of who's global
strategy by calling for a comprehensive
approach to vaccination
screening and treatment
princess rightly concluded that the
cervical cancer elimination
is both possible
and smart economics
christian
back to you
thank you very much dr teddrus with this
we are opening
the floor for questions from media when
you get called up on please
um
on mute yourself
we have a long list already and we'll
start with lauren sierra from swiss news
agency lauren please unmute yourself
yeah thank you for taking my question a
question on on the tests because a south
african study uh tends to to show that
salivary tests might be more accurate
and more efficient to identify the omega
variants and that wasn't the case with
delta
uh
yeah doesn't mean that we should
shift massively towards salivary tests
in order to better identify that variant
thank you
dr funke
uh thanks very much for the question um
it's a good question um as you know
there are a number of tests that are
available to detect the stars cov2 uh
virus including the omicron variant
um we have been evaluating all of the
tests that are being used pcr tests
the antigen based tests that are out
there
particularly the eul approved ones as
well as others that are being used
around the world some of these use the
the swabs that you know
up the nose the nasopharyngeal swabs
some from the throat and there are also
tests that use saliva
we encourage
the use of multiple types of tests that
can be used
i'm not aware specifically of the data
you mentioned in the study that came out
today but we do know that the tests that
are in use right now remain sensitive
to the omicron variant they can detect
this variant including the antigen-based
tests the pcr tests and saliva based
tests that are out on the market as you
pointed out in your question
it's not the time to make a massive
shift to recommend one or the other what
we really need to do at a global level
is to ensure that testing is accessible
is affordable and is reliable in all
countries and that testing is linked to
action so that the patient that is being
tested knows what to do
the goals remain to to reduce
transmission and so it's really
important that we know where the virus
is where the virus is spreading
and that people know how to get into the
clinical care pathway to receive the
care that they need
and that is needed in all countries not
just in high income countries or middle
income countries in all countries so we
have been working to ensure that
affordable reliable tests are accessible
we'd like to see more antigen-based
tests being used because these are
cheaper they tend to be a lot cheaper
they tend to be quicker in terms of
getting results back but again it's
important that those results are used
for public health you know and for that
individual to help that individual and
that they're accessible around the world
thank you very much dr van kerkov next
question goes to colin kretler from
bloomberg corinne please unmute yourself
i um
i just wanted to ask him because in
light of the reports out today about
animals like hamsters um being infected
with covet and
um being cold i just wanted to check on
the latest
insights from the who on the risk of
animals harboring the virus because
i think there was a consensus a while
back that such animals have little
chance of infecting humans
thank you very much corrine and we go
back to dr van kerkov um thanks corinne
for the for the question so we are
working with a number of scientists
around the world experts around the
world as well as our partners at fao and
oie are our partner agencies focused
particularly on animal health and
looking at animal susceptibility to
cyrus cov2
across a wide variety of species
this is done looking at experimental
infection as well as natural infection
that's detected out in in wildlife and
in domestic species we understand there
are a number of species that can be
infected with cyrus cov2 um and then of
course you there's the possibility we
call that a reverse zoonosis you know it
goes from humans back to animals and
then it's possible for the animals to
reinfect humans
that risk remains low um but it is
something that we are constantly looking
at because what we don't want you know
is to have as this virus circulates you
know it has the opportunity to infect
people as well as animals
and so this is something we need to have
better surveillance on
looking at around the world not only
which animals are susceptible but to
track this in animals over time i will
use this also as an opportunity to say
that of the seven million sequences that
have been shared around the world and
submitted to platforms like jose and
we're grateful for platforms that can
can house this material so so people can
analyze this
around 1 500 of those sequences are from
animals
and so what would be very helpful for us
and our partner agencies is to really
understand the extent of this infection
in animals as well
beyond people of course so that we can
track this and understand
what risk this may pose
so this is something that we are looking
at we don't talk about it very much up
here but we have many working groups at
the looking in animals at the animal
human interface to look at the
possibility of humans infecting animals
as well as animals infecting humans back
again
thank you very much dr van kerkov
next question goes to gabriela sotomayor
from progreso gabriela please unmute
yourself
hi hola
do you hear me
yeah very well
okay okay thank you thank you very much
um
my question is from mexico
a president of mexico
said that omicron is a little coveted
for people who are already vaccinated
it's a covizito in spanish he said but
cases and hospitalizations in mexico
begin to increase exponentially
not enough tests are available in
various parts of the country
and that there's a lot of worry about
children
children have not been vaccinated
children between 5 and 12
very few children between 12
and 17 years old
so there's a lot of concern because of
the high index of childhood diabetes and
also obesity
so my question is what is your with this
scenario what is your forecast for
mexico and what are your recommendations
thank you so much
thank you
this has been something that's happened
with every wave of disease particularly
with omicron that an exponential rise in
cases regardless of the severity of the
individual variant leads to inevitable
increase in hospitalizations and that
we're seeing that not just in mexico
we're seeing that north america other
parts of north america we've seen that
in europe
and we're beginning to see that in other
parts of the world so that that's not
that's certainly
not unusual and who has been warning of
this since early december
suggesting that speaking purely of this
as a mild virus or less severe gives an
impression that this would be less
severe in its impact on the health
system that is not the case if the virus
is able to spread uncontrollably
throughout society and that's why we
have advice continued
adherence to measures to try and keep
the virus under control while we protect
the health system and get through this
wave so i don't think the experience of
the challenges faced by mexico are
exceptional compared to other countries
certainly for the for the most part
children who experience
sars kobe 2 or cobit 19 have a mild
course of disease there are a subgroup
of children with underlying conditions
that do
potentially have a more severe course of
disease and many countries have moved to
include them in vaccination programs
and again as the director general has
said the pathway to
a long-term
control
of
the impacts of covet 19 and ultimately
on the pandemic itself lie in increasing
the number of people who are vaccinated
particularly those who are vulnerable so
i don't think the situation or the case
of mexico is exceptional in all
countries are facing a very similar
scenario right now as we try to get
through this wave of disease marine i
don't know
thank you very much for this
let's move on to
shoko koyama from nhk shoko please
unmute yourself
hi christian thank you for taking my
question um regarding omiku
last week the technical advisory group
of coffee 19 vaccine composition issued
an interim statement
quote
the composition of current covet 19
vaccines may need to be updated to
ensure that covet 19 vaccines continue
to provide related to recommended laws
of
protection uncourt
i just wanted to clarify
do you consider at this stage such an
update is necessary in order to provide
levels of protection against infection
and infection and disease by omicron and
if so what's your message to vaccine
manufacturers thank you
now thank you for the question no uh
again the the statement was clear that
the vaccines may need to be updated and
you'll also recall in the same statement
the tag go back asks that researchers
and manufacturers could move ahead and
produce small batches of vaccine that
could be tested
for their possible
utility and use
at a later stage the the issue here is
that the vaccines right now that we have
are providing very high levels of
protection against hospitalization and
death against all of the variants
every time someone gets a first dose or
a second dose or in the case of a third
dose in vulnerable people
not only
are we increasing
antibodies against the disease but we're
helping the immune system become more
mature
in its response so dr sumiya may wish to
speak to this but this isn't just a
matter of boosting to get antibodies
this is a matter of how quickly does
a mature and long-lasting immunity
develop and there is a certain group in
our population who may be
immunocompromised or may have underlying
conditions and they don't generate a
robust immune response with just the
first dose of the second dose and they
may require further doses now they're
called booster doses in future we may
have an extended primary course for a
subset of our population
so um from that perspective i think it's
very reassuring we were very
uh blessed uh globally and lucky in many
ways that so many of the original
vaccines proved to be so effective
against star scoby too and we're also
in that sense very pleased uh and
grateful that the vaccines remain so
effective against
the omicron variant in terms of
preventing hospitalization and
preventing deaths
and no at this point who does not have
any immediate attention to advise a
change in the in the composition of the
vaccine but there are many
considerations we'll point you back to
that document another journalist online
the committee do outline the specific
considerations and the specific options
that will be on the table and what they
would like is to have that discussion in
a data-filled environment and what
they're asking researchers and others to
do is to go out generate the data bring
that data back so that we can have a
global discussion
based on global needs where the public
and the private sector can engage in a
dialogue that allows us to collectively
develop the next generation of vaccines
and that this does not become a
unilateral choice of any
individual or any individual company or
any individual
system to be able to dictate
what the world needs in terms of future
vaccines these are very important
decisions and there is a lot to consider
there are risks and benefits every time
you move away from a given set of
therapeutic or preventive interventions
there are rewards in doing that if
you've got new products that are better
but there are also risks in doing that
if you don't uh sustain the benefits
you've got from the products you're
already using so these are important
policy considerations that must be
driven by good data and open transparent
discussion on on on what that data
actually means and i suppose this speaks
to the absolute heart of why science
must be at the heart of the next phase
of decision making regarding what we
collectively choose
on this planet as any second or third
generation vaccine sprucer some of you
may wish to comment
doctor
yeah just to add a point to what mike
has just made shoko because the way you
hear this discussed in the press uh
sometimes for a now i don't want to make
enemies of the press who get it so right
but sometimes this is discussed a little
uh lightly as strain change or switch
and remember every time that you make
that
a switch or you consider a switch in the
strains there's real costs right it has
an impact on production it has an impact
on output certainly in the short term it
also has an impact on costs it has an
impact on price it has an impact on
program complexities to try and roll
these things out as an impact on your
communications agenda and you know what
we're trying to do here is put out a
fire as fast as possible and take the
heat out of this uh crisis by reducing
the amount of hospitalization and death
as mike has said get the pressure off
the health care systems and so any time
you think about those strain chains it's
going to have an impact on access and
again the whole focus right now the one
thing we've learned is we all have got
to get out of this together so this is
why this is a very big decision to make
those kind of changes so like mike said
there are real
risks as one does this as well it can
have real impacts on your ability to
optimize access and mike made the
comments sometimes back
that the best vaccine is the vaccine
that you can get as rapidly as possible
and then we start building from there in
terms of people's immunity so
i think it's always useful to think of
the counterfactual in terms of important
decisions like this as well
so just wanted to very briefly add that
the tag go back was set up
basically to to keep track
to pull together the threads of data and
evidence that are coming from all of the
other different
working groups that who has set up
including the r d
blueprint vaccine research group
as well as the tag on virus evolution
and and and bits of evidence from all
over the world essentially to determine
firstly whether the existing vaccines
need any change or not and i think we
want to emphasize again that we're
tracking all of the vaccine
effectiveness studies that are being
done around the world and are very
reassured by the fact that the current
vaccines are protecting people against
getting severely ill and getting
hospitalized and dying and we can see
from the epi curves that
that maria had talked about
that the
absolutely explosive increase in numbers
luckily has not been
accompanied or has been disor associated
from the deaths that we've seen
in previous
waves
so
the tag go back will look
to see whether there is there is a
change needed and if so
um they have several options that they
will consider the first one of course is
to move to a variant specific
vaccine and again it's complex because
one needs
to take on board the fact that if you
develop a very specific vaccine that's
on a very specific spike protein
is that going to essentially undermine
the response to another variant that may
emerge in the future so
the vaccines we're using currently are
using the original strain and and
they're holding out
well especially against severe disease
as we mentioned the other approach is to
take a multivalent vaccine to have maybe
two different uh
sets of epitopes from two different
strains maybe the original strain and a
variant and the third and preferred
approach is to go for a pan coronavirus
vaccine that will protect
um
at least against all the variants of
sars cov2 but eventually one would like
to have a vaccine that protects against
the other beta corona viruses the
pathogenic stars one mers etc
or perhaps even the other groups of
so that's something in the future but
we have to pursue all of these
simultaneously the industry is working
companies vaccine companies are
investing in these different approaches
and we've heard from the different
companies what they're doing so that's
that's also good but what's good for the
world what's going to be not only the
most
efficient
but also affordable cost-effective and
practical approach
uh for the world because again coming
back to vaccine equity it's not
it's not okay for one country to take an
approach um which then uses up uh
available supplies
which could have gone to vaccinating
people around the world so we have to
keep vaccine equity because we cannot
get out of the pandemic and we've said
this many times but it is very important
because
it uh if we want to end the pandemic
then we have to take an approach
that is scientifically valid but also
equitable thank you
thank you all
next question goes to balisa gohinya
from double jaw
w magazine
portugal police please unmute yourself
hi
hi um my question is
will the same booster be the last dos to
add card global immunity to
the covet
virus um can you explain a little
more
uh on the subject in other words
if everyone in the world
had been fascinated with the booster
those
would the pandemic still issues
thanks
we didn't quite get the beginning of
your question but i think we go on the
if everybody
okay let's try to repeat please uh
belissa goes the beginning we couldn't
hear
my question is
will the blessing booster be the last
unstood
for global immunity to the conflict
virus
will boosters give
global immunity lasting immunity to the
virus is that what we heard
so i can start and maybe bruce or kate
may want to go come in so this question
of the boosters is also something that
we've been looking at very closely and
again we've always said that we will
follow the science
and what the science is
telling us now when we look across the
different vaccines that are being used
around the world because if you remember
there are three aspects that can affect
immunity one is
the um the person and their own status
the older you are the more you know
underlying conditions you have or if
you're on immunosuppressive drugs then
your immune system may be weak
and so you may need additional help to
boost that immune
response so it's the biological factors
the second of course is the the variant
and we've seen with uh starting from the
beginning the ancestral stain
different variants have had different
levels of immune escape and with omicron
we know that it has the highest levels
of immune escape or immune evasion that
we've seen
across all of the variants so far beta
and gamma also had that and then we
the third variable of course is the
vaccine itself and there are differences
between the different vaccines in what
how high the antibody response is how
long the protective immunity lasts and
so on but again the good thing is that
across all of the vaccines high levels
of protection against severe disease
that's the outcome we're most interested
in protection against death
against omicron many of the vaccines
have shown a reduction in efficacy
against
infection and that's why we see a lot of
breakthrough infections but these are
mostly
not resulting in severe disease so
so that's a positive
there is some waning which occurs over a
period of time and we've seen that
there's a slight drop in the protection
again mostly against infection but also
a little bit against the severe disease
and we need more of those studies we
need to follow this out
and that is why we've said putting all
of this together
the aim is to protect the most
vulnerable to protect those at highest
risk of severe disease and dying those
are our elderly populations they may not
compromise people with underlying
conditions but also healthcare workers
because if a lot of healthcare workers
get infected as we see now they can be
out sick and we don't want them getting
severely ill so to reserve boosters
for that population
there's no evidence right now that
healthy children or healthy adolescents
need boosters no evidence at all
so
this is why the sage which is our
technical
expert body that makes policy
recommendations
has been meeting and will continue to
meet will meet later this week to
consider the specific question
of
how should countries think about giving
boosters to their populations with a
view to protecting people
with a view to reducing deaths and then
of course we're looking ahead to to the
next generation of vaccines that perhaps
will block infection
more efficiently than than the vaccines
we have today and then we can think
about
you know really trying to control
transmission but as at this point of
time of our focus considering that we
still have so many unvaccinated people
in the world
is to vaccinate provide primary doses to
those who have not been vaccinated so
far while at the same time trying to
protect the most vulnerable in every
country's population um i don't know if
anyone wants to come in maybe you just
supplement too because i think serbian i
think we've discussed this before
um
because it's it's it's it's going to be
unrealistic i think people do have a
certain fear out there that this booster
thing is going to be like every two or
three months and everyone's going to
have to go and get a booster and i don't
think we have the answer to that yet um
i think it's going to be very important
again we're back to this issue of
science and data that we collect the
data because having having us a third
dose of vaccine may raise your antibody
levels but your long-term benefit may
not be the rise you get in antibodies it
may be
that that third um that third dose is
allowing your immune system to mature
and i think it's important that people
realize that the immune response to the
presence of a virus or to a vaccine
in producing antibodies that's very
simple understanding of what happens you
get infected or you get a vaccine and
your body produces antibodies and it
fights the infection and the infection
goes away and the next time it happens
the antibodies just show up and they
take care of the infection and that's
true to an extent but the immune
response is is a much more complex
process it's a very complex biologic
process
and it involves the the the b cell
system the antibody system and the t
cell system which is mediated by cell
immunity and that long-term maturation
the immune response matures over time
and the more that someone is exposed or
the more that someone is vaccinated that
can add to the maturation of the immune
response and the immune response can
become much more long-term
much more robust when the virus or the
challenge arrives back and i i we won't
go into detail here and i do think it's
very important now that we have many
people around the world getting third
shots that we look at how the immune
system is reacting to that and how long
the protection is from a third dose and
there may be cases of people who have
very
poor responses to that or people who are
very immuno compromised or
very elderly there may be a need for a
fortos and i suspect over time we will
come up with with that with an evolved
way of looking at what we consider to be
primary series and it may be that a
healthy adult has a primary series of
two two doses it may be that someone in
an older age group has a primary series
of three or four doses that's what we're
learning and that's why we need to
collect the data to be able to
understand what the long-term best
decisions are in deploying the vaccines
that we have at our disposal
thank you and i understand we have dr
kate o'brien director immunization
vaccines and biologicals who wants to
weigh in
yeah thank you just a couple things that
i wanted to add to what has already been
discussed around the table
the first is that everybody around the
table has emphasized the importance that
we follow the data we really
make policy according to what the
evidence shows and are driven by the
evidence
and i think this is such an important
point because at this at this point at
this stage we're still in the early
stages of understanding omicron
and the performance of the vaccines
against omicron
there are only four studies
that have reported on hospitalization
outcomes of omicron
a number of others that have reported on
infection
but not necessarily that severe end of
the disease spectrum and although this
is actually quite extraordinary to have
14 studies altogether at this point on
the performance of the vaccines given
that omicron really has just been around
for a couple of months
nevertheless there is a very important
need for additional data to help guide
the answers to the questions that you're
asking
the second is that the majority the vast
majority of people who are still being
hospitalized are those who are
unvaccinated
and i think we just can't uh
you know go past this question without
emphasizing again that a question on
boosters is really a question about
making sure that everybody who is
especially in the highest risk category
has at least gotten first their primary
doses because you can't be talking about
boosters unless you actually have people
who have received their primary doses
and then the the third thing i just
wanted to comment on also
is
how much we now know about being able to
mix and match the vaccines
and that's another area that seems to
have the potential to confer at a
benefit that some of the combinations of
the vaccines
may be
better in fact at doing what mike just
described around
maturing and advancing the immune
response that every dose is not just one
more dose
compared with the others that have
been received before that each dose
actually does um uh active things with
the your immune system does very active
things that
develops your protection more and more
in a way that is not just additive
it really is making your immune response
a much more mature and responsive
reaction to to
and protection for a future exposure
thank you
thank you very much all um a quick note
i understand there's some interpretation
issues on
the zoom link uh so one way out for you
we're trying to fix it of course but one
way out would be to watch the stream on
the wjo side it should be working well
there
next question goes to jen willa
from china daily
chen please unmute yourself
hi yeah my question is uh regarding i
mean dr teddy's talk about the divide of
the world of vaccinated unvaccinated but
i want to also
uh seek your answer on you know this
world divided by country uh practicing
like a zero coveted policy like china a
few others and some countries who
basically give up uh considering the
omnichis
you know uh
signals uh the coming of endemic you
know and some actually say i don't know
the truth that
you know a country practicing zero covet
will be actually vulnerable later
because their population are not exposed
enough to virus
thank you very much
what's your way forward i mean what's
your preferred way forward i mean
thank you very much jen yes comparing
the various approaches dr mike ryan
please
um
yeah i i think we have to be careful
when we try to compare strategies
because very often the starting
conditions of this pandemic set up the
opportunities or the the the the
countries had
so uh for example uh uh countries in
many countries in asia took a very
aggressive uh position at the beginning
and kept numbers very low so a zero
covered policy was open to them because
they had good control on the virus other
countries really got caught
blindsided by the virus and had very
large and extensive transmission so it
was very difficult for them to think in
terms of zero codeword because in fact
many many countries have never been out
of covert they've had
they've gone from high levels of covert
to slightly lower levels maybe to low
levels of time and straight back up so
we've had these progressive waves so i
think it's very difficult to say that
one country's strategy is the right
versus the wrong you a country strategy
in the face of the virus is based on
what the country is experiencing what
the opportunities are for the country
the country has to make a judgment as to
for example how good is this testing
system how
compliant will people be and how
cooperative will people be with with
public health and social measures all of
that has to be taken into account um so
i think it's it's difficult but it is
also and we've heard people say well now
the countries that have had a zero
covered approach you know are at risk
but i would much rather be in the
situation that for example south korea
finds itself in
which is
low zero prevalence in the sense of low
natural infection high vaccination and
only six thousand debts over the last
two years
i want to be in that group if i'm a
country now if that means that my risk
is increased because i have a lot of
susceptible people that i haven't
vaccinated then i will try and fix that
i will try and plug that gap and there
are risks and those countries who have
managed to successfully keep their covet
at a low level protect their populations
and now get their vaccination levels up
higher for them it's even more important
that they continue to vaccinate and find
and vaccinate those who haven't been
vaccinated
it is really important for them but to
in some senses there's an implied
criticism in that the countries that
went for low covet who went to control
the virus have now in some way created a
risk to their population i would much
rather be in a situation where the vast
majority of my population had never got
covered infection has now got high
levels of vaccine protection
and
may have a slightly higher risk now
because we didn't have
massive covert over the last two years
so i think
again i think it's important that there
isn't we don't imply that these
countries have taken a a wrong way
and zero kobit has not been in many
countries some countries have had a zero
covered strategy but they have
realistically known that it's impossible
to get it to zero unless the rest of the
world does i think the zero covert
approach has been in the main in
countries a focus on suppressing
transmission to the absolute maximum
protecting populations with vaccination
having very intensive surveillance
having a very flexible system of public
health and social measures a dynamic
flexible response aimed at keeping
covert transmission to the minimum aimed
at keeping the health system free of
severe disease and using vaccination to
fill in the immunologic gaps in the
population
if that's a zero cobalt policy it has my
full support
but sometimes again i think the argument
becomes uh
slightly twisted and people saying of
course it can't be zero why do you have
a zero covert approach it's not possible
i think most people who have had a zero
covert policy know in their hearts that
you can't get to zero covert in one
country unless the whole world gets
there but what they're trying to do is
keep kobod to the absolute minimum to
protect and preserve the health of their
populations and to try and keep their
health systems safe from the surges that
other countries have experienced now
having said that some countries did not
get a choice in this they ended up with
a massive wave of kobit in the beginning
and they didn't have a zero corporate
option they basically had to swim
against
the tide
and that's not easy either so again
please do not take my words
in saying that the zero covert approach
was the one to take because sometimes
that happens at these press conferences
what i'm saying is the strategic and
tactical choices you get in any crisis
very much depend on the situation you're
in some countries made really good
choices some countries
didn't necessarily
thank you much doctor ryan dr van kerkov
yeah i'd only want to come in not
specifically on any particular country
but to support that now is not the time
to give up on the strategy um you know
we're hearing a lot of people suggest
that omicron is the last variant uh that
is that it's over after this um and that
is not the case because this virus is
circulating at a very intense level
around the world you will see in our
weekly epidemiologic update that will be
published in a few hours that there's
another 20 increase in cases in the last
seven days with almost 19 million cases
that have been reported to us and again
that's a true underestimate of what is
actually circulating around and the
deaths are holding steady around 45 000
deaths per week and that shouldn't be
happening because we have tools at hand
and so it is not the time to give up on
the comprehensive strategy that we have
outlined that many countries are using
and as mike has
said implement them in different ways
but the goals of reducing severe disease
and death remain
the goal of reducing transmission
remains and we can do that now so what
we don't want to see our countries
giving up we don't want to see countries
abandoning
well
established life-saving
interventions distancing well fitting of
masks investing in ventilation where we
live where we work where we study
avoiding crowds making sure that we have
good public health systems in place now
is the time to strengthen that because
if we don't do this now we will move on
to the next crisis and we need to end
the crisis that we are currently in and
we can do that at the present time so
don't abandon the science don't abandon
the strategies that are working that are
keeping us and our loved ones safe
and what we can't do is believe in any
false hope there is so much hope that is
out there in terms of ending this severe
disease that people are dealing with
with the life-saving tools that we have
now this is a dangerous virus but there
is hope out there because we can reduce
severe disease and death significantly
with earlier clinical care with vaccines
that are reaching those who are most at
risk around the world
this won't be the last variant of
concern so now is the time to support
and invest in the surveillance systems
that we have around the world so that we
can detect these variants that we can
assess these variants with our partners
around the world so that we could
improve the advice that we give at a
global level that's implemented at a
local level that we could advise on what
the next vaccine composition will need
to be if that needs to be changed so
there's a lot to be hopeful for but we
have to put in this work and i just
wanted to take this opportunity to say
now is not the time to abandon the
strategy abandon the science and abandon
what we know works
thank you very much both and we have dr
bruce about
actually it was covered by now but i
think maybe chen just to think about
your point one other way about not you
know throwing in the towel
people are concerned about variance this
is a bit of the unknown the joker in
this in in this this crisis that we're
dealing with and remember
if you give up you end up with more
transmission more people infected which
means that you get more replication of
the virus you get more mutations more
risk in terms of the variants not just
people infected so it's
you you've got to bear that in mind
there are consequences or additional
risks that we are taking if you uh were
to say you know throw in the towel as i
think people have used the expression
here a little bit today there are real
um consequences and we don't understand
all of those consequences so to the
point that mike has made maria you
really want to reduce transmission as
much as possible we don't fully
understand the consequences of letting
this thing run and most of what we've
seen so far in areas of uncontrolled
transmission has been we pay the price
with the variants that emerge and new
uncertainties we have to manage as we go
forward
thank you very much all of you and we go
to jacqueline howard from cnn jacqueline
please unmute yourself
yes thank you so much for taking my
question my question is as companies
like pfizer and moderna work to develop
omicron specific vaccines could those
variant specific vaccines be used for
primary vaccinations globally this year
instead of the current vaccines so
essentially would they replace our
current vaccines or do you still see the
current vaccines uh being of use for
primary vaccinations and do you view the
variant specific vaccines more so
as uh booster vaccines
uh that's my question thank you
jacqueline thanks very much we'll look
at kate o'brien for us starts director
immunization vaccines and biological
skate
yes thank you you've asked a great
question
uh and the answer is that we're really
going to have to see the evidence on the
vaccines before any decisions are made
about what would be the best way to use
the vaccines and the reason i say that
is that
of course what's being pursued
is to improve the vaccines both for the
performance of protection against
disease but also as sumiya said
to protect uh and improve the
performance of the protection against
infection and transmission and really
the characteristics of these uh new
reformulated vaccines we're going to
have to see what those characteristics
are
and what the difference is if any
compared with the current formulations
you laid out some interesting ideas that
we're all thinking about of how they
could best be used and that of course is
um really uh as i said really based on
the evidence of what the vaccines do but
there's a whole other dimension to this
which is the scale and the volume of
vaccines that are needed uh around the
world to protect people um right now
here and now uh not
10 months from now or a year from now um
and we've certainly seen in the past
year that scaling vaccines um and then
deploying those vaccines into every
country around the world is an
undertaking that's not for the faint of
heart in any way and so i don't think
there should be any expectation
that um that vaccines that are
currently under development um you know
making adjustments uh to the best
anticipation possible
would suddenly become the entire source
of supply for all vaccines around the
world we have billions of doses that
have already been deployed billions more
that are being deployed and really the
focus has to be on continuing to get
those primary immunizations
into people
even while the this work is being done
to
establish whether or not these altered
vaccines could perform in a better way
and what the characteristics are that
would best use those vaccines to impact
um protection for people in all
countries around the world so yet to be
yet to be yet to be known and yet to be
decided but certainly issues that uh our
expert committees are already
deliberating on anticipating um and
eagerly awaiting
the results of studies that are underway
already thanks
thank you very much and dr swaminathan
just to add to what kate said
again to repeat that existing vaccines
are working very well uh particularly in
protecting people
from getting severely ill so we've seen
and kate mentioned this that most of the
people in the hospital any country you
take or any city
are unvaccinated so let's just remember
that we have very good vaccines now and
we need to use them we need to vaccinate
more people
um
for whatever reason they haven't been
vaccinated many people even in countries
where there are supplies
there are huge gaps in those populations
as well and of course there are many
countries in the world which do not have
supplies which is what covaxes
has been set up to try to bridge so i
think that's the message that we want to
get
that we're not waiting for micron
specific
vaccines at all
we
these vaccines are working and we need
to get them out uh to people so that's
the first the second is of course the
danger is that you'll be always trying
to play catch up with the next variant
because it takes several months to
develop a variant specific vaccine you
have to be tested it has to go through
regulatory approvals
and
and that may take six months and then
you may have another variant by then
there is no guarantee as
we've said repeatedly that there won't
be another variant and that it could be
very different from omicron so that is
why that we need to take different
approaches
yes variant specific vaccines is one
approach but then the better approaches
may be to have multivalent vaccines or
ideally to have a pan coronavirus
vaccine so multiple r d approaches we
have to continue to
to support
r d
and the development of of new vaccines
and many organizations including sepi
one of the kovacs partners uh is
is doing that
and so
um
and that tag kovac
has been set up basically to make make
those recommendations so
yes i think this is a space to be
watched
but as of now i think it's it's
reassuring the data that we have
thank you very much dr swaminathan this
brings us to the end of our briefing
today thank you all very much for your
patience and for standing by
um as usual we will have the audio
recordings
posted
right after the press conference and dr
terra's remarks of course and the full
transcript will be online
as of tomorrow morning
with this let me hand over to dr tedders
for the final remarks
thank you thank you christian and thank
you to all
media colleagues who have joined today
and see you next time